[Musique]
[Musique] [
Musique]
[Musique]
je pense que le
membre moyen du public dans la rue
ne devrait pas trop s'inquiéter à ce sujet d'
accord je ne pense pas que ce soit un problème majeur je
pense que c'est intéressant d'un  du
point de vue du virologue, regardez comment la mutation
change avec le temps,
mais cela n'affecte pas vraiment la
gravité clinique, cela
n'affecte presque certainement pas la
réponse vaccinale et la protection,
les gens doivent avoir examiné cette mutation n501y
et regardé où la mutation s'est
produite et  essaie de prédire
à quel point cela aurait changé la
forme de la protéine et ils ont probablement et
il semble qu'ils aient compris qu'en
fait cela ne le changera pas tant que ça,
donc les anticorps induits par le vaccin, la protéine s,
devraient toujours s'y lier et  vous
protéger
contre le virus
[Musique]
si suffisamment de mutations frappent cette protéine
au cours des 12 prochains mois, par exemple, tout
comme avec la grippe,
vous devrez peut-être modifier un peu le vaccin
pour l'adapter au nouveau virus afin que le vaccin pour
l'année suivante
peut devoir être modifié avec un gène codant pour l'
antigène protéique différent
pour s'adapter au nouveau virus et nous le faisons pour
la grippe chaque année, donc ce n'est pas une grande
chose ce n'est pas une chose alarmante
le virus aura tendance à évoluer vers un
virus moins nocif parce que le virus  veut
survivre il veut que l'
hôte survive il veut que la personne
infectée survive afin qu'elle puisse produire
plus de virus
et le propager davantage donc généralement
un virus plus transmissible a tendance à être
plus bénin
[Musique]
le problème avec ce virus est que la
maladie le  la gravité de la maladie
a tendance à être un événement médié par le patient hôte,
elle a tendance à être très médiatisée par l'hôte,
donc ce que nous ne savons pas, c'est comment cette
mutation
dans cette protéine peut changer la façon dont les
réponses immunitaires du patient y réagissent et c'est
quelque chose dont nous avons besoin  à
surveiller à l'avenir